new covet guidance from the american
academy of pediatrics
recommending that all children over the
age of two wear masks when they go back
to school
even if they are vaccinated that
suggestion comes despite cdc advice that
vaccinated students do not need to wear
masks
more than four million children have
been infected during the pandemic
and there are fears that number could
rise due to the delta variant and loser
coveted restrictions
president biden's chief medical advisor
dr anthony fauci joins us now with more
dr fauci good morning
good morning let me start there with
children it's confusing guidance for
parents
which to follow what do you advise that
parents do with their students when they
go back to school
well i think they should do what has
been locally asked for
namely if the local schools the the the
the pediatric the academy of pediatric
actually makes that recommendation that
children should be wearing masks
uh from two years old onward uh that is
in
i would think the extra step of caution
in general that is a bit
uh different from the cdc guidelines
but right now the cdc is carefully
looking at that
and hopefully we'll have some now
concordance of the recommendations
but the reason for what the academy did
was
because of the high degree of infection
dynamics that we're seeing if you look
at the map of the country right now
there's an uptick in cases in virtually
all the states
in the united states and for that reason
they want to go the extra mile to make
sure that the children are protected in
school
and obviously everybody wants to see
children back in school you know there
are diseases obviously where
vaccinations are required things like
smallpox or mumps
should the covet vaccine be on a list
like that that's required for children
to be in school and have that
vaccination
that might actually occur that is not
the situation right now
but i could imagine as we get further
into this and we see where we're going
with this outbreak whether or not is
going to be essentially
with us for a considerable period of
time i would not be surprised that is
not a policy right now so
don't anyone get confused by what i'm
saying what i am saying is that i would
not be surprised
that in the future this is something
that would be seriously considered
depending upon how we handle the
outbreak if we completely crush this and
it stays away and there's very little
activity at all which i hope happens
that right now that's not happening but
if it does happen then i don't think you
require that but if we go
into this year and the next year and we
see we still have a problem with this
it very well might be required and you
talk about that spread especially with
the delta variant
right now only about 50 percent of the
country a little less
are fully vaccinated you are everywhere
there are vaccines everywhere they're
available what else can the federal
government do
at this point to get more people
vaccinated
well what they're concentrating on is to
try
and get trusted messengers to get to
people who are recalcitrant
about getting vaccinated and try and
explain to them the importance not only
for their own health but for that of
their family and for the community in
general i mean people
like your family physician or clergy or
respected members of society
whatever it takes because you're
absolutely right this is untenable
to have an outbreak of this type and to
have
relatively speaking even though a lot of
people are vaccinated
a lot of people are not vaccinated and
those are the ones
that are getting infected in fact
there's this striking statistic that
people
should really pay attention to 99.5
of all the deaths due to covet 19
are among unvaccinated people that's a
striking statistic
so when people are unvaccinated and they
look at that hopefully
they'll really take a look at that and
say wow i mean really for my own safety
and that of the community
it's very important to get vaccinated
put all other things aside
ideological differences political
differences
and they just focus on what this really
is it's a public health issue
a very serious public health issue and
as you said
that's the reason why people should
seriously yeah and i was gonna say as
you said numbers don't always tell the
full story but right there with that one
it certainly helps give perspective dr
anthony fauci thank you for the time